[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jana
pareigis schönen guten abend und
herzlich willkommen an diesem sonntag
nehmen wir für den sport norbert könig
die wichtigsten nachrichten des tages in
den nächsten zehn minuten für sie
zusammengefasst
weiterer schritt richtung ampel nach der
spd sprechen sich auch die grünen für
koalitionsverhandlungen aus
vereint gegen ministerpräsident orban in
ungarn setzt die opposition jetzt auf
einen gemeinsamen kandidaten für die
parlamentswahl
und licht aus in china der staat
verordnet billigen strom energiekonzerne
schalten deswegen immer öfter ihre
leitungen ab
jetzt fehlt nur noch die zustimmung der
fdp
dann können die verhandlung für eine
ampelkoalition beginnen die delegierten
der grünen stimmten heute mit großer
mehrheit bei nur zwei nein stimmen und
einer enthaltung dafür währenddessen
stimmt sich die union auf die
oppositionsrolle 1 britta spiekermann
berichtet
bündnis 90 die grünen sagen ja kleiner
parteitag große zustimmung auch wenn
viel von licht und schatten die rede ist
die zuversicht mit spd und fdp eine
koalition bilden zu können überwiegt
deutlich wir haben es geschafft mit den
politischen partnern oder den parteien
die vielleicht bald unsere partner
werden einen aufbruch zu schaffen eine
echte dynamik eine hoffnung stiftende
dynamik die möglichkeit aus einem
vierklang
verantwortung in einem einklang zu
schaffen zweiklang allerdings bei
personalfragen habeck will offenbar das
finanzministerium fdp chef lindner und
wohl auch über koalitionsverhandlungen
werden die liberalen morgen entscheiden
die spd hatte bereits am freitag
zugestimmt jetzt arbeit an der basis der
mindestlohn soll kommen höhere steuern
für reiche aber nicht er ist doch
selbstverständlich dass in seiner
zusammenkunft von drei sehr
verschiedenen partnern jeder seine
herzens themen einbringen können aber
natürlich auch nicht alle verwirklichen
musik als stimmungsaufheller im
westfälischen münster die junge und die
alte union versuchen sich zu sammeln und
gehen der ball schon einmal in position
es gibt ja den einen oder anderen der
sagte respekt vor diesen sondierungs bad
ist ja gar nicht so links ich kann euch
nur eins sagen das ist die strengste
links agenda die wir seit jahrzehnten in
deutschland gehabt haben die da in die
sondierung papier niedergeschrieben ist
die grünen beenden heute ihren kleinen
parteitag in feierstimmung jetzt wird es
ernst die ampel fest im blick
grüne und spd haben koalitionsgesprächen
also bereits grünes licht gegeben theo
koll morgens noch die fdp daran ist da
alles in trockenen tüchern oder kann das
noch scheitern na ja wir haben hier 2017
gelerntes tücher feuchter sein können
als es von außen manchmal den anschein
hat aber ich erwarte das auch die fdp
morgen zustimmen wird parteichef lindner
und auch generalsekretär wissing haben
beide heute sehr eindeutig für das
verhandlungsergebnis geworben und
hilfreich gegen innerparteiliche
kritiker dürfte es da war übrigens sein
dass auch konservative kronzeugen aus
der union wie friedrich merz oder armin
laschet es sondierungs papier gelobt
haben dennoch kann die aufbruchstimmung
natürlich noch in katar hinten denn
viele wichtige punkte sind ja bisher
eher verklausuliert angesprochen die
frage der finanzierung ist noch eine
relativ fest verschlossene milliarden
teure wundertüte und natürlich geht es
am ende bei der postenverteilung auch um
egos und um einfluss auch da ist
theoretisch noch raum für rabatz
dankeschön und
theo koll hat gleich auch noch mehr zu
den ampel gesprächen und der
orientierungssuche der union bei berlin
direkt
schauen wir auf die aktuellen corona
zahlen das robert koch institut meldet
acht 1682 neue infektionen innerhalb
eines tages das sind 1070 mehr als vor
einer woche die sieben tage incident
steigt weiter und liegt derzeit bei
72,7
in ungarn läuft es bei der opposition
zur zeit nach dem motto der feind meines
feindes ist mein freund sechs politisch
bislang tief gespalten oppositions
parteien von links bis rechts haben
heute das erste mal in einer vorwahl
einen gemeinsamen kandidaten für die
parlamentswahl bestimmt das ziel
ministerpräsident orban im kommenden
frühjahr von der macht verdrängen wolf
christian ullrich berichtet er liegt bei
der auszählung aktuell klar in führung
peter mark ii sei konservativ streng
wirtschaftswissenschaftler
voraussichtlich mit ihm möchte die
ungarische opposition im kommenden
frühjahr viktor orban besiegen vor drei
jahren wurde er bürgermeister in einer
hochburg von orbans fidesz-partei so
soll es ihm nun im ganzen land gelingen
wir wollen eine koalition der sauberen
politik es wird ein gemeinsames programm
umgesetzt wichtige elemente der linken
grünen aber auch die liberalen seite
vorhanden sind
ein handschlag auf eine faire
zusammenarbeit die ungarische opposition
von ganz rechts bis ganz links will
gemeinsam mit einem spitzenkandidaten
orban besiegen anders ist deswegen des
wahlrechts kaum möglich
urbans rückhalt bröckelt vor allem wegen
seiner corona politik justiz und medien
hat er in seinem system der liberalen
demokratie gleichgeschaltet die eu zum
feind erklärt orban und seine freunde
haben viel zu verlieren für die
opposition wird es ein hartes gefecht
nach norwegen dort herrscht mittlerweile
traurige gewissheit bei der gewalt hat
im kongsberg vor vier tagen ist auch
eine deutsche getötet worden mit einem
trauergottesdienst wurde heute der fünf
opfer gedacht ein 37 jähriger däne hat
die tat gestanden
die polizei geht mittlerweile davon aus
dass der mann psychisch krank ist ein
terroristisches motiv hält sie
inzwischen für wenig wahrscheinlich
und wir blicken nach china der winter
naht und das lässt die sorge über die
stromausfälle weiter wachsen denn schon
jetzt geht in vielen landesteilen
ständig das licht aus sogar fabriken
müssen zeitweise dicht machen dass die
gleich an mehreren gründen wie pekings
klimazielen und dem deckeln der
strompreise durch die chinesische
regierung
details und folgen der stromknappheit
von stefan die schöne baum in der
nordostchinesischen stadt shenyang ist
plötzlich der strom weg wie in vielen
städten chinas
straßenbeleuchtung und ampel dunkel
menschen bleiben in aufzügen stecken
fabriken die nicht produzieren aber die
auf einmal keine jobs mehr einige
schließen dieselgeneratoren an damit sie
nicht pleite gehen
vier tage lang hatten wir keinen strom
im moment können wir es uns noch leisten
aber wenn das länger geht dann sind die
kosten zu hoch und wir werden nicht
überleben
schieß regierung hat ein problem denn
die versorgungsengpässe sind hausgemacht
er will günstige strompreise für sein
volk also hat er niedrige strompreise
festgelegt das aber bringt die
kohlekraftwerke in finanzielle
schwierigkeiten denn sie verdienen kein
geld kohle macht aber 70 prozent von
chinas stromversorgung aus die
kraftwerke haben ein ganz engen
spielraum für tarife und wenn sie jedes
mal viel geld verlieren schalten sie ab
gleichzeitig will ping sein land bis
2060 klimaneutral bekommen mit hilfe von
regenerativen energien
hehre ziele aber an der realität scheint
china zu scheitern denn der winter steht
vor der tür da werden die heizungen
planmäßig an diesem wochenende wieder
angestellt deshalb muss jetzt erstmal
wieder strom her das heißt mehr kohle
und mehr co2 es kann also passieren dass
das netz überlastet dass es dann zwar
warm ist aber in china an vielen orten
wieder das licht ausgeht
seit sieben jahren demonstriert peggy da
jede woche in dresden nicht
unwidersprochen denn fast ebenso lang
gibt es gegen demos päda gilt als
rassistisch und wird vom
verfassungsschutz als extremistische
bewegung beobachtet
zahlreiche bündnisse hatten heute gegen
proteste organisiert in rufweite von p&g
da setzten mehrere tausend menschen ein
zeichen gegen hass und rechtsextremismus
und bekommt zum sport da hat der fc
bayern in der fußball bundesliga erst
mal für klare verhältnisse gesorgt haben
so sagen den verfolger bayer leverkusen
hätte sogar noch schlimmer treffen
können fünf tore davon vier binnen
sieben minuten haben die münchner den
vorher punktgleichen leverkusenern schon
vor der halbzeit eingeschenkt entstand
521 je zwei treffer von lewandowski und
gabri diese und alle anderen tore des
achten spieltages gibt es ab mitternacht
in unserer mediathek bei sport pte in
torlaune ist der
handball-bundesligist der sc magdeburg
siebtes spiel siebter sieg 33 zu 28
gegen die sg flensburg handewitt
sie sind zu recht aus team der stunde
der sc magdeburg der momentan auf einer
welle des erfolges regiert im
spitzenspiel kopieren sie die sg
flensburg handewitt vor 5000 zuschauern
führt das team von bennet wiegert die
gäste zeitweise vor liegt schon zur
pause mit fünf toren vorne auch nach dem
wechsel ist es der klub weltmeister der
das tempo bestimmt flensburg an die
großen personellen probleme nicht
kompensieren die norddeutschen sind
chancenlos gegen magdeburg das in dieser
form schon jetzt anspruch auf den
deutschen meistertitel erhebt und wenn
auch noch früh in der saison
gestern 0 zu 1 heute eins zu drei die
deutschen hockeyspielerinnen haben zum
auftakt der pro league auch das zweite
spiel gegen belgien verloren
zwei spiele null punkte für
bundestrainer klavier eckinger gibt es
beim nacholympischen neuaufbau noch viel
zu tun in der ersten halbzeit findet
seine noch junge und unerfahrene
mannschaft kein mittel gegen die
belgierinnen die zur halbzeit schon mit
2 0 in führung liegen deutschland hat
wenig zwingende torchancen schafft aber
immerhin den anschlusstreffer durch
diene kurz der mögliche ausgleich
gelingt aber nicht den schlusspunkt
setzt belgien in der letzten spielminute
mit dem tor zum 3 1
[Applaus]
schlusspfiff das war danken wir sind
aber noch nicht ganz am ende wir schauen
natürlich noch wie das wetter wird
morgen scheint nach auflösung der nebel
und hochnebelfelder auf die sonne nur im
nordosten bleibt es trüb in küstennähe
regnet es zwölf bis 19 grad bei
dauernebel bleibt es kälter und am
dienstag ziehen von westen regen wolken
heran am mittwoch ist es überall
unbeständig und zeitweise stürmisch
um 21.45 begrüßt sie hier claus kleber
mit dem heute journal